okay time for audience questions for the
week first question hey David why are
people calling what Donald Trump did a
quid pro quo instead of just calling it
bribery or extortion very good question
and something I've been talking about
for a while the the media cycles are
basically referring to it as a quid pro
quo and what I realized was the problem
was that there was a lot of debate over
whether it was a quid pro quo without
people knowing what quid pro quo means
which of course the the gist of the
Latin is you scratch my back I'll
scratch yours something for something
else something in exchange for something
else this for that it is not in a
literal Latin translation although I
think that it's it's generally accurate
when in reality if you don't actually
understand what that means you might not
understand that we're basically talking
about actions by Donald Trump that would
be bribery or extortion so let's look at
the definitions here quid pro quo
define in English would be a favour or
advantage granted or expected in return
for something so it does describe what
took place with we need you to do us a
favor the military aid smear
investigations of Joe Biden by Ukraine
and the Ukrainian president Solinsky
quid pro quo is not an inaccurate term
but a lot of people don't understand it
and it's probably not a strong enough
term bribery on the other hand the
giving or offering of a bribe which is a
sum of money or other inducement offered
given offered or given to bribe someone
seems to me much more precise and
actually much more indicative of the
true sort of nature scope and severity
of what has taken place the bribe is to
persuade someone to act in one's favor
for example by smearing Joe Biden
typically illegally or at least
dishonestly or immorally you could argue
via a gift of money or other inducement
it is literally what is believed what is
alleged to have taken place between
Trump and the Ukrainian president there
was the attempt by the Trump
administration including on the July 25
phone call but also beyond it what led
up to it as we know in other
conversations the idea was let's
persuade you
crane to publicly announce an
investigation of Joe Biden and hunter
Biden for the purposes of hurting Joe
Biden's chances in 2020 to help Donald
Trump in exchange for a gift of money or
inducement in this case it was military
aid money for the country now what's
interesting about that is the attempt to
persuade on that basis is the bribery
regardless of whether the bribe is
accepted or ever actually paid and that
is another reason why we really should
be calling it bribery instead of quid
pro quo quid pro quo accurately or
inaccurately is often interpreted as one
thing for the other and the things are
exchanged when you look at the different
definition of bribery and what a bribe
is the language makes it much more clear
that the attempt the persuasion attempt
the inducement regardless of whether
it's accepted still counts as it as a
bribe as an attempted bribe as bribery
and that's really important and then we
also get to extortion now the definition
of extortion is the practice of
obtaining something especially money
through force or threats so you can say
that when you consider the geopolitical
imbalance of power between the United
States and Ukraine you can reasonably
make the case that when a white house
when the Trump white house tries to
obtain smears on Joe Biden from Ukraine
they are using force and threats
is it physical force no Trump is not
saying he's going to show up and punch
president zalenski it's not that but
when you consider the power dynamic we
could certainly argue that it is the use
of force to obtain something from
Ukraine and that in that sense it also
qualifies as extortion so these are
certainly more commonly known and
understood terms I believe that they
more precisely describe what it is that
took place so I think that we can't not
use the term quid pro quo at all because
it's still in the conversation but I'm
gonna make an effort to say what is
being described as a quid pro quo it's
actually bribery and
even extortion I think I'm gonna start
making that point every time and I
appreciate you bringing it up to me